hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on new world again and
today we're gonna be talking about a new
blog post that came up now there's only
the text format at the moment there may
be more questions in terms of what's
going to happen with the video format so
if there is a video format later today
and there's something totally different
than we'll talk about it but at the
current moment we're gonna be talking
about the blog post and this is gonna be
about making your mark and the
settlements and the government system
within the game staking a claim and
working together as a community is a
critical step on the path to dominance
in new world HRM is divided into
distinct territory as many of which have
their own settlement and forth to find
out more about how you can own a piece
of HRM we sat down with lead systems
designer John Liberto
to discuss the ins and outs of
settlements and governments in New World
I'm pretty sure that it's pronounced HRM
but definitely let me know in the
comments below if I got that wrong so we
have pretty much what it seems to be
what's two things are called settlements
and then one of them is called forts and
we're gonna be learning a little bit
more about those specifically right now
so settlements are where players can
live congregate craft trade and work on
town projects and support their faction
through faction missions death is not
the end in aeternum so settlements also
serve as respawn points for players
unfortunate enough to have fatal mishaps
on their adventures you can claim that
these settlements are in the early
stages of the game players must choose
between one of the three factions more
in a future developer blog so we get to
definitely learn about more factions in
the future once you choose that faction
you can create or join a company what a
company is created inherits the faction
of its creator companies can gain
control of a territory in the settlement
or fort that it contains if the
territory is uncontrolled this is as
simple as paying the claim fee at the
territories for if the territory is
already controlled by a company the
territory must be taken through war
which can only occur between companies
that belong to different factions we'll
delve further into war and its other
domain of mechanics and an article so
stay tuned for that so of course more
news on that but they've already
mentioned kind of what faction wars and
company wars were which we talked about
in our past video and kind of how they
were in the Alpha a lot of things would
probably change from then till now a
settlement is where players own homes
craft refined items trade and take on
faction missions and socialize whereas
the territories fort is the main point
of defense for a territory it is what
comes under attack during PvP and
invasion
emissions and it's where players need to
go to claim and unclaimed territory you
could become the governor by becoming
the leader of a company initially a
company's governor is the person who
created it when a company takes control
of the territory the governor of said
company also becomes the owner of the
territory now for some people this might
be just a little bit confusing and I can
totally understand that what as it seems
like right now there's going to be three
main factions in the game and they're
all going to be having little
subdivisions as I will call them and
those subdivisions are player controlled
and created companies those companies
are going to be pretty much clans of the
faction that they represent as opposed
to some games where you just kind of
join the faction and everybody's all
groups technically you could still be
part of the same faction but you may be
a part of a different company then if
you happen to go to a territories fourth
which is way different than a settlement
the and then you take that over either
by playing the claim fee or by taking it
over through PvP combat the leader of
your company whoever happens to be that
leader will then become the governor of
that section this may not be important
for a lot of players but for the players
that definitely want to take that
governor role ultimately the faction
that has a company belongs to the true
ruler of a territory companies act as a
proxy for the faction that they are a
part of as a governor your
responsibility is to maintain control of
the territory for your faction you're
also responsible for upgrading and
maintaining the quality of life in your
settlement by starting town projects
that result in settlement upgrades
haven't completed dues in the form of
territory upkeep must be paid to the
faction your company is a part of or
it's a pay this upkeep the governor can
adjust taxes and fees and their
settlement so that travelers and
residents help to pay the upkeep as they
trade craft and live in their houses
they can also make their settlement more
desirable to own a home by focusing on
particular upgrades for particular types
of players so this is very intriguing
it's actually kind of got this whole
money in banking system that isn't just
hey you take control a little bit boom
and then next faction comes in has
enough money to buy it off you or they
fight in that CID it's all about
actually keeping it up and not just once
you get it you get it you have to
actually stick with it so there is going
to be definitely some situations where
someone ends up taking it over but then
they realize they don't have the funds
to keep it up and then it gets lost
almost immediately so this is a very
different kind of style that at least to
me I'm not used
there's also a thing called a console
which is going to be the governor's
second-in-command a company can have as
many or as few consoles as it wishes
consoles have almost the same
permissions and powers as the governor
of the company and territory that
control ultimately though a console can
do things the governor might need to do
in the governor's absence being a
governor can be a demanding role to play
in new world the console rank in a
company is a way for governor's to share
some of that responsibility with other
company members that they trust so more
of your second in command your helper a
governor that isn't actually a governor
sediments are also going to be equipped
with what looks like crafting and
refining stations upgrading these
stations enables higher quality and more
powerful items to be crafted by the
players and spend their time there
additionally a territory's lifestyle
buffs and for upgrades are controlled by
the governor lifestyle buffs are
powerful long-term bonuses for things
like crafting in combat that only apply
to the territory's residents we also
have a picture on the screen which looks
like one of the new territories called
Brightwood there is ZERO out of 35
upgrades so this governor has an up
creamiest single thing and they can
improve the lifestyle upgrade the fort
and also upgrade the village and they
can also do a few other things with
upgrading that fort like weakening
invasions and preparing for Wars so it
seems like there's a hell of a lot of
things they can do and of course that's
going to take a lot of time so you got
to really pick what you want to do first
and choose it wisely residents are
people who own houses in your
settlements if a player does not own a
house in a settlement they will not
receive the territories lifestyle buffs
like the other upgrades lifestyle blocks
can be activated through town projects
set by territories controlling company
and we're going to be getting into
territories in their town upgrades just
in a moment but it does seem like these
residents I actually originally thought
that these were just going to be regular
NPCs but the residents are actually
other players so it's more of it's not
just getting NPC's to come into your
town it's getting other actual players
to give that incentive to stay in your
place so that you can keep the upkeep
and keep up with the fort which is a
totally interesting system in my opinion
like I said we're gonna be talking about
town projects and these are large-scale
activities that people can work on
together and upgrade their settlements
town projects require a significant
amount of effort and investment from not
only the controlling company but the
players that that settlement calls home
town projects are activated by a
settlements governor or one of their
consoles when a town project is
activated players in the town can
missions that progress the project
towards completion these missions award
XP and currency among other things but
more importantly they advance the town
project for example let's say that you
want to upgrade your settlements Forge
which will enable weapon and armor
crafter secured a higher quality gear
arms and armor for the adventures to do
so you would have to activate the
upgrade forge town project and then UN
members of your company and anyone else
living in town can work together to
complete these projects on screen
there's a bunch of different projects
that these people have we have
activating the chef's passion which is
after getting a certain amount of XP it
seems like by killing a bunch of animals
getting some hides getting some silk we
can upgrade the gates by killing a
couple corrupted finding chests in
ancient temples and also acquiring some
ore in the top-left we can upgrade the
carpentry by getting some more raw hides
and some silk and then also weakening
the innovations of PvE content by
killing some corrupted finding more
chests and acquiring some leather so it
might seem a little bit tedious after a
while but I would assume that there's
going to be a lot of more unique things
added to these kinds of things so that
it's not just the same all I get to kill
20 peer again grab the raw hides and go
back and it's not this tedious project
there will probably be a lot more things
but it does seem like there's a lot of
different things you can upgrade at one
time and for what it looks like on the
top left the upgrading of the carpentry
it has a 34 hour mark I don't know if
that actually gets taken down by a how
many times you upgrade things by helping
out the team with the raw hides and the
silk does that far go down or do you
have thirty four hours to complete some
of these objectives or you can actually
not upgrade the carpentry each time a
town project completes the settlement
levels up the settlement begins to level
down when upkeep is not paid to the
controlling faction or if players fail
to repeal a corrupted invasion which of
course at the PvE content they're gonna
be digging more into PvE content of that
corrupted invasions more down the road
towards the closed beta but as it stands
now the PvE content no one's really sure
what it is but it's definitely gonna see
in like a full-scale invasion of some
type of species and I think that's
really cool kind of keeping the people
on their toes while you can use the
services of any settlement in the game
that you join one by purchasing a house
there anyone can live in any house and
any settlement regardless of which
faction they are in or which company
controls the territory if the territory
does change hands the rest
of the settlement are generally
unaffected aside to any changes to
taxation upgrades and lifestyle buffs
the new controlling company might make
we will have a lot more information on
player housing in a future developer
blog whether you aspire to be a governor
a highly valued citizen or a simply a
wandering adventure settlements are
place you will want to call home and
protect a fight so this is some
interesting dynamic that I've never
really experienced in some game before
imagine you finally get this player home
and you're totally cool with it a really
nice area personal and whatever you
happen to like about it whether the look
or the area surrounding it whatever it
happens to be and then all of a sudden a
all-out war brawls out and now the taxes
are twice as high the payment is twice
as high for everything and now you don't
feel like it's home anymore which causes
lower upkeep to that new company which
they might not be able to pay because of
how much they're ruining their citizens
so it's got this little bit of balance
that you definitely have to keep aware
of when you're playing and it's really
really interesting in my opinion yeah
let me know if you guys think about the
stuff in the comments below I'm actually
a super super excited for this kind of
implementation of the settlements and
the forts and the companies I'm very
curious to see how this is going to work
out I know a lot of people are skeptical
about the PvP and what's going to happen
but at the moment we're not talking
about that just yet and who knows there
might be a whole 180 in the PvP
Department whether that be good or bad
in the future but at the current moment
we're talking about the settlements the
consoles the governors and as it stands
I think this is a really sweet system
and I think this can you know bring a
lot of activity to the players and keep
them intrigued because they got to keep
their settlements alive every month or
so or whenever the payment happens to be
and I think that's a really cool system
yeah let me know what you guys think
about this stuff in the comments below
like the V if you're doing Joe subscribe
if you're new and with that guys take
care of a girls today peace out and I'll
see in the next new world video bye
you
[Music]
[Music]